sont concernés dès maintenant toutes les
personnes âgés de 5 ans et plus la
vaccination des enfants de 5 à 11 ans
inclus nécessite le consentement des
deux parents est la présence d'au moins
un parent accompagnateur muni du
formulaire d'autorisation parentale
est ce que vous allez vacciner vos
enfants qu'elle en avait nourri foulée
retrouviez d'avoir
désormais parce que je me suis juste ma
peine été voir dans le laos et j'ai
trouvé la diffusion du du vaccin c'est
quoi un vaccin réellement c'est ça la
raison mon truc il a travaillé
j'ai un peu changé sur le poêle à métro
et dans la brousse ouais dans la roue
soit la même substance pathogènes qui
inocule et individus lui confère
l'immunité contre une maladie d'envoyer
d'accord que dans ce dans le cadre de
notre vaccin c'est juste un traitement
pour éviter de tomber gravement malade
c'est par un vaccin quand on a besoin de
la polio ont la choque pas d'accord
maintenant est ce si long sur les en est
là c'est pour ça que et puis qui m'ont
causé par un vaccin je vais jamais le
faire pour mes enfants vous avez des
enfants de quel âge et calage à bages en
est un qui accueille celui celle qui est
censée 8 à 77
16 mois 17 21 et 25 sites où les
voitures vous votre question elle est
totalement pertinente moi je prends mon
exemple personnel ma fille ma fille à la
saison elle y va ce que vous allez faire
alors elle est vaccinée a aujourd'hui là
j'ai une grosse pensée pour elle mélanie
elle a été déclarée positive à
aujourd'hui même un test elle est
positive qu'elle va plus à l'école on ne
comprend plus rien car les parents moi
je me dis on va me traiter de l'avancé
bah j'avais discuté avec elle et sa
maman tout le monde était d'accord et
finalement je me disent que j'ai pas
fait une énorme erreur parce qu'on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya dans ce vaccin
escarra pas d'effets secondaires qui
peuvent être majeures dans des dizaines
d'années pour elle et puis là elle est
vaccinée elle est positive donc quand on
est parent on est perdu je me pose
d'énormes questions tombent d'accord
alors valérie vous avez un enfant de
cinquante six mois il est grand il ya
vingt ans donc hissé vacciner mais assez
mais je comprends tout à fait que sur
les sur les mots alors un sauna
d'enfants de l'appartement et danser
c'est ça la qualif 20 voix moi non moi
c'est la question est là pensez vous
vous êtes dans la cible hinault et
bianca qui on eu 20 épisodes à fond moi
c'est dans laquelle la question dès lors
c'est non bon ben moi c'est non nous
enverrons à l'armée on parle de cinq ans
dont on parle de six ans alors c'est
facile ici de dire moi aussi je pourrais
dire mais dans mes enfants ils sont
vaccinés 17 ans 20 ans s est pas moins
ses fins je voulais pas
j
attends ça c'est fait mais maintenant
mettez vous à la place des gens qui ont
des enfants de 6 ans auront des enfants
de 7 ans
c'est facile de dire
lui va dire là et nous dit cyril hanouna
moi c'est non mais quand lino et cinq
camarades de lino les parents ont décidé
de faire vacciner leurs enfants elin on
lui dira tu vas pas au fast food avec
tes enfants parce que t'es pas vacciner
trois légèrement on va sortir non mêlant
le format mais on va sortir lino de la
vie et on va sortir votre enfant de la
ville c'est cécile y cédera c'est donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé clash et la
vaccination des 13 14 15 ans avec leurs
passes vaccinale leur pass sanitaires on
a sorti des gamins de la vie et quand on
ne guérit taka theresia quatre gamins
qui dit je peux pas aller au restaurant
avec mes enfants au fast-food bas mais
moi le vaccin et les parents ils ont
mille voyons c'est sur les entreprises
ont fermé nous
tue à la cinémathèque
au-delà de ça en fait il faut le
consentement du papa et de la maman déjà
11 ans lui
fondé des conneries
tu dis des conneries maintenant j'ai
recruté les lieux mais depuis quand est
médecin kato l'a
déjà la vaccination
si pas du tout en formant des deux
parents et l'accompagnement des eaux
qu'elle franchit la tranche 5,5 on sent
rin kagura donc on est d'accord c'est
finalement mon chéri je te jure que
c'est ça c'est aujourd'hui alors ils ont
changé
[Rires]
la mauvaise essentielle pourquoi c'est
mon pote se ressemblent catherine toi tu
ferais tu fais vacciner des enfants
alors moi si j'avais des enfants non je
ne les ferai pas vacciner est ce que je
voulais dire c'est que effectivement le
vaccin ça divise tellement c'est pire
qu'un sujet point monsieur lamy au sein
d'un coup par exemple moi j'étais
totalement contre la vaccination est bon
et du g20 g8
moi j'ai dit à roger situe même à winter
vaccine pas dans lui il m'a dit si tu
m'aimes tu te vaccine et tu restes mais
vacciner et c'était moi même à la base
ici tu m'aimes tu te barres
donc là on va avoir des parents ou les
deux vont devoir se mettre d'accord
sachant que aujourd'hui un parent sur
deux est séparée donc ça va en faire
plus de sujets de discorde c'est hyper
compliqué c'est facile de dire ça c'est
hyper facile de dire moi je vaccinerait
pas mes enfants mais quand ton enfant
pourra plus aller à la piscine mais non
cinéma et non mais là c'est pas le cas
pour l'instant mais pas le terrain
maintenant la nouvelle prévision est
basée pas de mauvaise foi avait raison
mais oui oui il a raison non qu'ils
soient fondées par des arrêtés on nous
avait expliqué que la vaccination des 5
11 non non non non non c'était pas aux
humains avaient finalement ça ne l'a été
et ça aucun sens de vouloir que toute la
population soit vaccinée et en même
temps de ne pas avoir de passes
vaccinale pourtour d'une tranche mais un
élément peut-être que je vais vous
donner puisque pour répondre à la
question yat il doit avant tout à
l'heure c'est moi je suis personne par
contre si ça vous intéresse je peux vous
donner qui est tombé l'abonnement ou son
émission l'étude publiée par mon
neurochirurgien après ça ils bossent
avec nous je crois allez allez un des
acteurs médicaux de monter de venture a
analysé la plus grande étude qui est
sorti par l'agencé européenne du
médicament et par le centre européen de
prévention des maladies infectieuses se
gare sur la question des onze ans
écoutez bien ce que dit connaissent
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui est dit dans
l'étude qu'est ce qui lie les autres
reconnaissent que les données sur
l'efficacité du vaccin contre la
transmission du variant des places sont
actuellement limitées et indisponible
pour la tranche 5 11 donc ça commence
bien marie serre que déjà donc allez pas
vous ça a été rédigée oms avait même
fait
il
n'existe pas de données précises sur
l'immunité naturelle chez les sujets non
vaccinés que ça durait est inconnu et
probablement été rejoint dans population
il précise quand tu es bien ce que je
vais vous dire allez l'émergence de
marcheurs ayant préoccupant introduira
de nouvelles incertitudes qui devront
amener à réévaluer l'impact potentiel de
la vaccination des enfants c'est pas
fini les effets secondaires j'ai pas
fini point les ai pas
les effets secondaires n'ont pas pu être
évaluée dès lors qu effectivement les
échantillons sont très faibles ma
cheville était là mais ça veut dire en
gros si je résume on sait rien série qui
nous a lu cinq minutes à pour dire le
salon
des visio nous on a fait les calculs
aussi de voir si effectivement vacciner
des enfants un impact sur l'épidémie
dont la population à nouveau reculer
aucun c'est à dire que vacciner les
enfants c'est pas ça qui va empêcher les
adultes cette année des agents
contaminants les enfants poussent pas
quoi pour les enfants moi j'ai trois
enfants dans la cible de 5 11 ans j'ai
pas l'intention des actionnaires d'accor
des strings question oui alors c'est
pour les enfants c'est sur les enfants
mais être est il exact est de plus en
plus d'enfants touchés contre un masque
en or il ya des jets des enfants qui
sont contaminés par le virus par le
virus après il ya quelques enfants qui
en général sont des enfants en très
grand surpoids ou tillon décor mobilité
assez importantes qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 65 ou tafer en décembre il ya eu
zéro décès
c'est martin pour les chips ya
effectivement comme nous le verrons
disais hier soixante et un enfants entre
4 75 à 4 il a raison 4 j'ai vérifié les
chiffres mais il a raison c'est même ça
s'explique en fait d'une manière assez
logique en réalité il faut savoir c'est
que les études vous dise que je suis en
chez l'enfant comme on sait pas trop dès
qu'ils présentent une pathologie
respirable la raison est qu'il est par
ailleurs positif au clubbing on va
l'hospitaliser d'accord pour
surveillance donc si j'ai une
bronchiolite est qu un petit peu qui
récompense un peu je vais être mieux
soit critique mais je vais être positif
au qu'ovide sa série en afrique du sud
et aux etats unis entièrement aucune
idée que ces 64 enfants ça pour
l'animation à la cause du candidat c'est
impossible aérienne